[Musik]
ach herrje was ist denn mit dir passiert
es ist nicht nur ein kleiner unfall so
sieht es aber nicht aus
hallo hallo hier geht es mir geht es gut
aber nico der arzt sagt es ist nicht
gebrochen
nach der absatz auch du sollst dich
ausruhen dr grube hat nur
schmerztabletten und eine bleibe
verschrieben
wir waren mit dem rezept schon bei der
apotheke nico papst dein klein nicht
bewegen okay nimm die tabletten dreimal
täglich und die salbe sollst du abends
vor dem schlafengehen benutzen okay okay
das machen wir solle die tabletten
morgens mittags und abends vor oder nach
dem essen nehmen nach dem essen danke
für ihre hilfe ich muss jetzt gehen aber
wir sehen uns nachher okay ja ich komme
mit und besorge uns etwas zu essen darf
ich mitkommen du musst dich ausruhen
[Musik]